jackson and al sharpton and obama and
the whole group of them told black
people to do that we'd have a lot fewer
of these things to deal with in the
first place yeah all right so i'm i'm
with you i i'm hearing a lot of what
you're saying here so as a black
conservative then who now you've you've
laid out your case there but you haven't
laid out yours i asked i asked you to
name the most important uh example of
racism and you gave white cops going
after black people and i and i told you
gave you the facts for that so that's
nonsense that you must have something
else what else is it if you think racism
remains a problem in america give it to
well i think it remains a problem
it may not be systemic in that we have
it's not like you're not being hired
because you're black there's no systemic
reason you know legal reason that that
exists that kind of thing but i think
that racism as a general
uh i need some theory i need something i
need some specifics right you gave me
the white cop thing what else give me
another example what do you think is a
problem
well well as a black conservative tell
me how you how do you get people to come
around you're the one who made the
assertion that racism remains a major
problem in america i asked you to give
me an example you gave me white cops
going after blacks i as far as i'm
concerned you didn't hold it up very
well what's the other argument you have
what's the other thing well i don't know
that it's systemic in that in the sort
of macro system i'm not bad i don't want
to know what it is you're you're talking
no right
why i know this has been just a thing
that
people have said about black people why
is it
why from your perspective why do you
think when
black people may be getting passionate
about someone something or like amped up
about it and it
it comes off as them being mad or upset
oh
i just think the guy on the left is
getting roasted and he's okay do you
upset like i think he knows
because i'm telling as someone in media
i know when i'm getting a viral moment
and you know when you're losing
like i've had people on my show and they
come with like facts and i'm like oh no
dang it like i don't
um well why do i think that i don't
think he seems mad i don't think the
other guy
i think he just thinks he's losing okay
because he
cuz he's gonna take it that way no i i
don't think he's mad at all but he said
i'm not getting mad just the fact that
he
has to say that yeah that he has to say
that it's like this shouldn't be a thing
you two you two are discussing something
like you shouldn't have to say i'm not
getting mad because
of what you're passionate about what
you're talking about you're trying to
help him understand and it's coming off
as excitement but
when it comes to black people comes off
as mad and i'm like
why it's like as you get excited about
something
you may have the same tone and voice as
him
but if
if we were excited about the same thing
and you were expressing it i was
expressing it
for me it may come off as like oh no
like don't get mad i wasn't trying to
make you upset it's like i'm not mad i'm
just like expressing it right so
i don't know
i never thought about it like that but
he like has to say that
and so i it's things like that
that he may not
it may not be
racist and he may he may think that
there's so racism is not a big thing in
the world but it's things like that that
it's like that is programmed
in us just like subconsciously
to
to like do or to say or people have that
reaction
and
like where did that all start how did
that all start yeah
i don't know
i just think that's part like that
reaction there is just part of the
debate and maybe this is just like my
bias and how i see it but like because i
find myself saying that stuff too to
people when i'm like kind of going after
and i'm just saying like like it's okay
but
but i'm about to roast the [ __ ] up
because then you know you're about to
get toasted like a marshmallow
but we're cool
yeah we're cool but let me let me just
roast it a little bit like do you
remember when um the girl the basketball
girl was on and i could just see her
getting like yeah and i was like i'm
sorry
i didn't say i'm not mad but i was just
like i'm sorry yeah no offense well i
just want to let you know this like you
know the fact that i'm about to
you're about to go viral
you're about to be put on the viral
train
yeah
i was gonna say something else but i'm
gonna just let him talk okay that's
that's exactly what that's yeah believe
me that's 100 percent so we can have
these are not getting into school bs
that we have a race we have affirmative
action so a black person with a with an
sat and a gpa
of x will get into a school faster and
easier than a white person with an sat
or a gpa of x and if going to going to
school is a route to the middle class
you can make an argument that black
seven easier route to middle to the
middle class if you're talking about uh
blacks about poverty um
the poorer you are the more accessible
loans and grants are for you uh the the
the problem the biggest burden that
black people have in my opinion again is
the percentage of blacks 75 percent of
them that are raised without fathers
and that has every other social negative
consequences connected to it crime not
being able to compete economically in
the country being more likely to be
arrested that's the number one problem
facing the black community and when i
hear people tell me about systemic
racism or unconscious racism i always
say give me an example and almost nobody
can do it
i wonder
if anybody has ever brought up
redlining and gentrification
within the communities because i
i'm not 100 sure about how
gentrification works but from what i'm
seeing back home
it's
it's in a sense like
not
not helping and i know
i know they say it's to
help the community look better help the
community
in xyz what is that i i think that's
that's when they move the lines for
votes right for gentrification yeah so
it may there may be other stuff but what
i know from it is they will take these
they will take low and commune low end
communities and
put
nicer housing in it so like if you were
to go to la right now or anywhere in
southern california in like the rural
areas you'll see all these nice
apartment buildings being built like
right in the smack dab of
these communities and it
essentially is taking the people that
have been there for years and moving
them out because these nice apartments
now are skyrocketing the prices of
living and it makes it hard for the
people that are living that have been
living at a steady rate
and
it pushes them out to
further work from where they are and i
don't know how that's
helping the community when the community
is being pushed out
and so i don't know if anybody's ever
talked to him about that or redlining
and most of these
um most of these
nice apartments that are being built are
in the redlining communities i just have
a question would it because in my head
wouldn't the nice neighborhood like the
nice
apartment complexes would bring richer
people with more money right
and so wouldn't that help the businesses
because like in the area because they
would have
money to spend on them and then like
then the businesses would be able to
employ more people that are low income
like because in my head that would help
but i could be wrong
it it would because the um
because obviously the rich people are
going to be able to pay more and help
the businesses out more but with that on
the other hand
it
is raising at such a substantial rate
that no matter if
they can employ the people that already
live there
it's like they don't have
like they're here and it raises to here
and they don't have that
safety net or that gap there to be able
to
get up there as quickly as it's rising
and so it's forcing them as they're like
pushing them out to where because i live
like on the outskirts of la county and
it's pushing them out towards us and
it's like taking
it's taking the community out of the
community so people who have lived there
for years or years
they're moving out to an area where
they've maybe never lived i'm just not
sure how you'd prevent that because it
just seems like
you know if someone
wants to buy a piece of property like
they should have the legal right to yeah
so i just i'm not sure how you could
really like what you could do about it
without passing some really wild laws
that wouldn't make sense yeah
that's it sucks because because you kind
of see that in new york where they have
a lot of laws to that like prevent
oh my gosh i read this book so long ago
so but i i know new york has a lot of
issues with housing because they have so
many laws that seem like they were put
in place to prevent something like that
like um they like rent ceilings okay
like where you can't raise the rent
above a certain
price but then
which sounds nice
until no then people are like why would
i
build an apartment complex
i'm not going to make any money
and then
in new york you always hear about they
can't find housing it's the same thing
in california actually yeah
it
finding housing in california is
ridiculous and
i
i couldn't tell you why and i wonder if
someone brought this up to him would he
think
that
it's because of there was some laws put
in place or did it stem from racism
um
like what do you mean like the red the
red lining and the gentrification
because essentially the
from my knowledge and stats may say
different essentially
what gentrification does
in these communities it
brings in the rich
the rich people the rich other and then
it kicks out the people that have lived
there and typically people that live
there are
black people from from my knowledge and
it may become right
my um
lack of knowledge maybe i don't know i
think it just sounds it sounds like to
me it's about money
because
because i think of my parents right and
when they they like they've invested in
properties before
and like we this this wasn't really um
like this this was like the town i'm
from is pretty white all together so
this this had nothing to do with race
but more money but like they purchased a
big piece of land and because nothing
was really there and it was just like
poor like farmers basically and now
the suburbs you know what i'm saying
it's like moving out okay and the price
of those has gone up yeah but that's
that's kind of like because when you
look at properties a lot of times you
want like to get a cheap plot of land in
a neighborhood that's coming up yeah and
then sell it for more later yeah i can
i can see that as well because
one
there's things that are coming to la
within
the next
four years
two years i think
yeah no 2028 the olympics are coming to
la and so there's things that they have
to put in place now
that
essentially
builds up la and i can see it being
money and not being
based off of racism because essentially
the more and more people that come to la
the more more money they bring in la is
a huge city for famous people for the
industry whatever it is that you're
getting into and now that
being a content creator is a viable job
now more and more people are moving to
la so i could be
i could subscribe
i could see i could see
nobody thinking it be about
about race and it'd be about money like
no i know i'm gonna get a little money
if i build here in this community and
the certain things that are popping up
around the community i i could see me
making bank here so i could see it like
that
do you think that despite what you've
said about uh president obama do you
think that now that he's out of office
maybe he could step into the role that
you'd like to see him in so instead of
america turning to jesse jackson and
farrakhan and sharpton
maybe they can turn to you but if not to
larry elder but if not to larry elder
that maybe obama when you disconnected
from politics can actually talk about
some of those things because i mean you
addressed it a second ago you said he
did mention the family and mentioned
fathers and all that so is there a
chance do you think there's a chance for
that i'm not optimistic because uh in
his last press conference he talked
about we still have a great deal to do
on race by the way when people talk
about a great deal to do on race all
they really mean is how black people
feel about white people and vice versa
they don't care about hispanics they
don't care about asians they really care
about the relationship between blacks
and whites
why why why is that
like i
why actually yeah we never hear about
asians yeah we
it's
i watched this clip but it was so long
ago i kind of forgot about it it's crazy
because
i
surprisingly i think about this stuff
sometimes and i i'll have conversations
with myself but i only know as much as i
know and so i'll be like i wonder why
and i've asked myself like i wonder why
we don't hear about
the way
or any other people besides black and
white like why is that
the main two group of humans that we
talk about so much it's like there's so
there's so many different people in
america
but the main two that we talk about so
it's just like
i wonder how other
other races feel like i want to be
talked about too i just remembered
something that i read in seoul's book a
while ago and he said if he wants to
test something for like
if it's about race right if they want
because you have to like measure racism
on some level like what you do is you
find a different group with the same
like skin color
okay
and so he would put it against like
indians like indian americans because
they're dark okay or you know what i'm
saying
and it's like
because i think he was talking about
economically like he wanted to see if
like
it would oh my gosh i'm butchering this
please don't clip this guys
and but he said it was because but like
indian americans do better than white
americans
they're like one of the highest
performing groups like lowest on crime
highest on
an income like they make more than white
people wow
obama has throughout his eight years in
my opinion when he could have ignored
the race card or put it in perspective
picked it up whether it's cambridge
police or whether it's trayvon martin if
i had a son he would look like trayvon
whether it's invoking ferguson whether
it's hiring somebody like eric holder
who's lecturing the country on race and
racism
obama i think believes that racism
remains this huge massive problem in
america despite his election and despite
his reelection and i don't and so i
don't think he's going to say the right
thing and do the right thing i think he
i think he's encouraged black people to
think of themselves as victims as
opposed to saying look at me i busted my
butt
my parents
made sure i had a good education i
didn't make bad moral mistakes uh i got
married before i had kids follow my
model and you'll be fine he has not said
that at all what he said is we have real
problems in this country he embraced the
black lives matter movement i mentioned
trayvon martin i mentioned some of the
other things in my opinion
the reason that a lot of people voted
for obama was because they thought he
was going to do exactly what you
suggested which is to heal us put things
in perspective
tell young black people they ought not
be angry when they're pulled over by a
cop all the cop is doing is his job
instead he did the opposite so i'm not
optimistic at all that he'll play that
kind of role that you suggest yeah
that's very very
interesting that he says that he as he
was talking
something that kanye west said
popped into my head when he said that
slavery was a choice
and when he said that
i was at first i was like what do you
mean like they didn't choose at all like
everybody else then i sat there and i
was like well let me
try to understand
what he is saying i'm not saying that
they volunteered as tribute to be a
slave
but
nowadays if you think
of yourself as
a victim
that's
a mindset and you're not like he was
saying that
barack obama he
we had a first black president
ever
and
it's like
you can shed light on the great things
and the thing the
way that the world world just america
has progressed over year for you to be
able to be in that position but if you
don't if you don't talk about that if
you talk about the
all the hard stuff we have to go through
this is hard this is this and that like
they're gonna be there but if you switch
the narrative and shed light on the
great things and how
america has changed then you'll get out
of that mindset and out of that victim
mindset of
everything everything is hard for me no
matter what it is because i'm black
everything's going to be hard no matter
how hard i try i'm never gonna be able
to do this because i'm black like no
like
yes there's gonna be things that
people you can't stop what people think
you can't stop people's actions but if
you think of like no i can do this
because of this and the third i can work
hard at this be this and if i see
somebody that's not black and i can
still do it it doesn't matter if i'm
black or whatever i'm gonna do it
because i want to do it and
[Music]
i feel like there needs to be
there needs to be more people
talking that way towards the black
community to shed light on like
look at where we've come from look at
all the great things that black people
can do now that they could not do before
xyz
and
how much you can do if you want to go
into the medical field if you want to go
into the tech field whatever field it is
you can do it don't let the things that
have happened in the past stop you from
seeing the progress of the country and
seeing that you have you have an
opportunity doors are being opened more
and more doors are being opened for
just people in general to be able to do
stuff also black people
well and you know it's interesting i
think one of the greatest ways to fight
racism is success
you're like because then they can't say
nothing about you
if you're successful like what you gonna
call me on my name cool i got i got
money i don't care it doesn't affect me
like call me anything you want what are
you doing breaking that family dollar
okay cool
i'm over here have my own business
running a million dollar company cool
call me whatever you want do whatever
you want
yeah i would send money
i want to i actually do want it
subscribe money
money money money
so the way we've demanded i hope i'm
wrong yeah i i hope you're wrong too i
don't know but is this a is this the
same interview or is this another no
it's the same interview it's all one
okay cause they're
they look different no no they're the
same it might be
no it's the same it might be a different
camera angle okay the way we've
demonized cops as part of this i agree i
mean i see a lot of times people are
just screaming about how evil cops are
and they're hunting people down all this
stuff
i don't know a ton of cops but i knew
some in new york and i know a couple
here i mean
generally they're trying to do good
right i mean
do you have any experience in which have
you ever been pulled over and
i probably have been pulled over maybe
more than almost anybody you know i got
my driver's license when i was 15 and a
half my learners permit and then when i
was 16 i was able to drive by myself and
i probably looked like i was 12. so i
got pulled over probably 100 times and
with the exception of one or two
instances the encounter was brief and
professional
one time a cop told me to take my head
out of my ass that was the first time i
got pulled over by the way my god i have
a story that i just thought of
do you remember that black lives matter
guy
he did this whole rant of how this cop
pulled him over for no reason right and
this cop was like i think it was in
michigan it was somewhere in the midwest
okay
and no he had this whole brand he puts
it on social media the cop comes forward
and shows the body cam footage
man didn't do anything oh wow this dude
like just made it up
wow
and see that's on the flip side that's
another thing
is that's why the camera is good thing i
think yeah definitely
because now
you it
there's people that try to like
go viral for because they know that
that's something i'm not saying
everybody for that situation it's like
okay
i don't know what was going through his
head but from outside looking in it's
like well why why would you lie on a cop
if the situation was
gucci and there's nothing that happened
and like you have people that be in
situations and don't lie on cops but
they
don't
they just don't get any like option to
come forth but you had a safe situation
but you want to lie and then it it's
like it puts
the real situations in a bad situation
you're like well then what if this
person was lying they they're all
like what what's wrong with the like
that is wrong like why would you lie
about that right there i first of all
sir you are making
money
why aren't you rich to be caught up in
that why and it's like yo you
ruined you've ruined
any possible
anything because you wanted more money
you thought in your head
i'm going to do this
and it's going to be great it's going to
work out perfectly
no but first why
you are a talented singer a talented
actor and your family is talented people
like
like
you could if you didn't like what she
was making on the show okay finish out
the season finish out the whole thing
and then do something else make music be
independent be on whatever else and then
up front say i want to make this much
and if they don't like it okay go on to
something else i'm like
you make
how much money on empire and you want to
do this to yourself and sir you're
you're dying you're done in the industry
well it's like how do you protect both
sides
that's the question yeah
i like i see both sides like actually
there's power hungry cops and there's
people that want attention on social
media and we'll use a real problem that
we have to get it yeah so how do you
i i don't have the answer i have for
sure i don't have the answer i don't
it's hard because it's like if you
if you try to protect
one side
the other side is going to lose
something and vice and vice versa or if
you try to protect both there's going to
be something that
doesn't make sense to implement
for one side or the other and it's like
i don't know
well and and the other i do think
that
if you're gonna go on social media and
accuse a cop of something you should be
willing to go to court
yeah because i don't think it's fair for
you to like have a public court of
opinion and sway people's opinion
without going to court and it's the same
thing i think with assault allegations
if you're going to publicly accuse
someone of an assault allegation like
you should be ready to go to court yep
yep but
i guess jesse was in fact ready he just
you know i will give him that he was
really he's he's got it all lined up he
had the
show written
right doesn't he he's willing to die
with this lie
i'm like sir
there's camera footage
and
it was so cold out
like look at i'm sorry the the crazy
trumpies they're there okay i i agree
with you there's some crazy trump
supporters
but they they're not trying to get you
in the cold in zero degrees in chicago
i'm from chicago no ain't nobody's
talking outside in zero degrees in
chicago i've been there in the winter
even the gang even the gangs stay inside
yeah they're like goes down when it's
cold it's too cold outside who i'm
shooting outside of your degree weather
my trigger finger gonna be frozen i
can't pull nothing
like
no
it's gonna be like this thing like you
know what
tomorrow we'll try it again tomorrow
it's gonna be two degrees warmer so
let's try it again did not not look at
like
he did not think this
and that's dedication on his half
because he he was willing to go out and
zero degrees to fake a crime
i at least respect i respect you willing
to die by the line
it just sucks because now like if that
situation if that situation happens to
someone they're gonna be like how do we
know they're telling the truth and
they're gonna have to go through even
more steps
to prove that this was like really
something that happened because of
someone else's stupidity yeah well and
you it makes you wonder how many times
has this happened and
nothing no because because the way the
way i look at
when things happen to celebrities it's
like indicative of the society so like
with amber heard and johnny depp
women have been getting away with abuse
that's been happening in society now it
happened to a celebrity so it's coming
to the forefront yeah so to me it's like
that had other people had to have done
this too and probably got away with it
the same way women got away with that
yeah but the question is how do you
protect both sides
i don't know let me know in the comments
because i don't if y'all have the
answers let us know because we don't
yeah i was driving and there was a light
behind me and i knew i hadn't done
anything anything wrong so i sleep going
the guy pulled over and screamed at me
and he goes why didn't you pull over and
i said what i said to you well i didn't
i didn't think i did anything wrong and
he said whenever you see some lights
behind you you pull over get your head
out of your ass and he was right i
should have had my head ahead of my ass
you know um uh the instances in which
cops kill blacks has declined 75 percent
in the last 45 years according to the
cdc while the instances in which cops
are cops kill whites have pretty much
flatlined and so
it's going down it is very very very
rare for the cops to kill anybody let
alone an unarmed black person of the 965
um people that were killed by the police
uh in 2015 less than four percent were
white cops killing an unarmed black man
it is very rare by contrast 400 people
were injured by lightning last year but
only 250 people were killed black people
were killed by police so it's very very
rare so how much of this i know you talk
about fake news and i want to get to
that but how much of this is
because the media is complicit in all
this so for example just this morning i
think the oscar nominations were put out
i haven't even seen them yet but
apparently there are more minorities
this time i guess there are some more
latinos and dev patel and and some more
black people right and you know for the
last couple years there's been this
oscar so white thing
to me
and i can only speak for myself this is
like keep your eye is just off the ball
you're just paying attention to the
wrong thing where
it's nice to have people nominated for
these things but they're irrelevant in
the scheme of
what's important uh what you should be
caring about is education and all that
but the media has made such an
importance out of this that it's like
it's getting the black community's eye
off what's actually important which
would be education and family and some
of the other i i i couldn't agree with
you more um
with the oscars thing um
i think it was i watched the oscars last
year
and i had noticed that there was more
um minorities that were um
in
the categories nominated that's the word
nominated and
i was like okay cool great and i but i
know like um a lot of them didn't win
because i think that year um
what is that one show from out here it
was like
uh
bridgette no no it was um
oh my goodness it was like how house of
something i can't remember but they
swept it every award was going to them
going to them going to them and i was
like wow
i don't know the thing behind the oscars
i don't know
[Music]
how they vote but just to have the
opportunity
to
see more minorities at the oscars was
cool and i liked it but in the end
people were like they had all these
great nominations but nobody won the sat
in the third i think oscars is like off
of like people voting but also the sales
that they made and stuff that happens
throughout the year
and if i'm wrong someone let me know but
um
whenever i hear people say like oh
this but like there wasn't
enough
uh black nominations or if they don't
like something i'm like create it
like if you don't if you don't like it
if you think that there should be more
of something
implemented somewhere create it if you
want an
all black awards show
create it there's a comedian who
um
i've followed him for years and he kept
getting a nose and nose from hollywood
and everything and so he created his own
his own streaming service and now he's
able to put out what he wants to put out
and employ people in the black community
the way that he wants to employ them and
it's like
if there's something
that's how i see it if there's something
you don't like
put it together create it if you want an
all black award show
go
for it
how do you know the difference between
like
racism and people just ending up where
they're supposed to end up
i don't i don't know yeah i don't see i
don't know because
i've there's certain instances where
it's just it is what it is and you can't
do anything about it and then there's
instance where it's like
you you get that feeling like what's was
that a little racist but
i
i don't i don't know i can i think about
that with like sexism too
where people will say like oh it's
because she's a girl or whatever but i'm
like how do you how do you know that for
sure
and it kind of goes back to like
i don't know like i don't know how you
would know
i don't i don't i'm never gonna say it
doesn't exist yeah but it's just like i
don't know how you would know the
difference between like those the people
nominated being just very talented all
together and it just happened that the
person that won was white yeah or versus
like someone behind the scenes at the
oscars is racist yeah
see i don't and then like they never
when they're calling out racism they
never say who it is mm-hmm like they
just say oh it's the oscars well there's
people behind the oscars so which people
yeah which ones call out the people
oscars is isn't just the statue yeah who
are the people actually doing it and if
you don't like it
whoever the oscar
people are
get them out get more people in there
that you want i don't know how that
works but then it goes back to
in another way quotas
do you want them do you want them
picking people
based on the color of their skin like
isn't that again saying they need
special handouts yeah
yeah and
this like will smith one i mean i know
he's in the news for the wrong yeah but
no one would ever say he got that award
because he was bl like no one would ever
say that he's so talented
yeah
on the flip side there's a
there's a
people that are i would say more
talented than will smith not knocking
that he's not talented that have never
received any type of awards
he's more talented than will smith
i would say
i would say denzel because he's you've
been in the game for a lot longer and
that's the first person that pops into
my really because i think a will smith
has been in bigger movies than him
now you don't think so
i'm not i'm not a movie person i'm not
like i'm not yeah i am not the one to
ask about this denzel has some heavy
hitters i just think of um seven pounds
and oh my gosh what's the one where will
smith was with the kid
the pursuit of happiness and happiness
i don't know what did denzel do the
pursuit of happiness i cry
i cry every time they're at the bathroom
name what will smith movie have you not
cried in
if you
if you see
any will smith movie
he something that me and my family point
out he
runs
almost everyone in his movie and he
cries it was like the two things
and it's it's a funny thing but that's a
little off stuff
a little off subject that's one thing
that i saw when during the war shows i
was like will
you cry that's that is you you are going
to shed a tear in your acting so it's a
part of you so i'm like are those real
tears or those acting tears
i had thought about that video wait wait
said what did denzel do that was better
than that what movie i'm not a movie
person so i don't i don't really watch
tv so
um you have a
training day as a big one have you ever
seen training day i don't think so okay
and then you have remember the titans
those are i know there's bigger ones but
those i think the pursuit of happiness
is bigger than those you don't think so
then why haven't i seen him
because um
because her past denzel washington when
he was younger i was like hey smash
he got a smash hello denzel
you know his name is pronounced denzel
and not denzel for real yeah he said
that it's pronounced denzel
i did not know that
i said why is this important to you
and he said because it provides role
models and enhances the self-esteem of
black people that's what he said
i said are you aware that black boys and
black girls have higher self-esteem than
white girls and white boys this has been
tested for decades it's been the case
for a long time and there are very very
few asian actors and actresses yet
asian americans japanese americans
chinese americans and korean-americans
on a per capita basis make more money
than virtually anybody else in this
country
that's another thing
that community
i feel like is
underrepresented in a lot of
film
tv
in a lot of industry based stuff
in um like the main things i feel like
they are
underrepresented
you really don't
hear anything from them and i often
wonder like if they
if they feel a way
like that they're not being
represented in certain areas well i
think it's just like what interests are
in a community like you know asian
people are over represented in academics
probably medicine i wouldn't guess
you know it's just like i think certain
communities like are more interested in
different things based on like values
like german i'm german right my brothers
are engineers
germans are very often like there's just
certain cultures that like
you know they tend to be in different
industries
so it's the question is is it is it
racism against asians or is the asians
just aren't as interested in
entertainment
hmm
it's like there's there's not a lot of
asian guys in the nba but nobody says
the words write out more yeah
and that's
and that's and i'm telling you once you
start looking at the world this way you
start to like think about it differently
because people always talk about
disparities
but what would
there's nothing that's out going to be a
hundred percent represented above the
pop like even if we took engineers
or a random job like there's no industry
that i can think of that's going to be a
hundred percent
represent exactly what the population is
yeah
like i got my gears turning
i'm just thinking about like different
scenarios where
one
one ethnicity is more in this area but
you don't
hear anybody saying well
we need more this in
this field or this area
like yeah and that's the other thing is
like you don't want a society where they
push we need more of a certain race in a
field like that's to me that's racist
like because i don't think it matter i
don't like on my show right people will
always comment they'll be like oh it's
like always like black people coming on
but and those are the people that want
to come those are the people that want
to come i don't cast it that way i just
say who shows up
exactly and like you were on the
basketball team there was two other
girls on the volleyball team you just
showed up more than they did you're more
interested in it yeah and it's like it
didn't it wasn't
in certain things i feel like it it it
shouldn't just it shouldn't be pointed
out
that
oh
the obvious shouldn't be pointed out and
it's just
it's frustrating because that's how
that's how it is like oh
you have more white people here than
hispanics or
um
orientals or blacks you have more this
than it's like
you don't know what
you don't know if they're trying to get
trying to get more to be able to
represent you don't know what they're
doing behind the scenes but people see
it at face file and then they
just say racist racist racism yeah or
even even on my shows right because i
kind of understand where people in
entertainment are coming from because i
recruit for these i've only had one
asian girl on my show yeah the whole
time i've but i've had more like white
people black people than than asians i
just think they're not
in that case as interested in
entertainment they're like no i don't
want to come on your podcast yeah
yeah because if it's not something that
is deemed
of importance
in the community in general
people are more hesitant to
to do it so like something like this
talking about this this isn't deemed as
popular from my knowledge in the black
community talking about stuff like this
but
you're you're gonna get people that are
going to
want to talk about this like me
i mean i was kind of forced to because
i'm getting red pill but no
but yeah
i give you the option to walk away you
know that kitty
you know that yeah yeah i come back
because i enjoy
it so it's utterly irrelevant yeah and
for us to pay attention to this and it's
also not true
if you look at the last 15 years or so
roughly 10 or so of the nominees for the
major categories have been black people
they've been a couple of years where
there's been a shutout uh but um add it
all up it's about parity with population
right so that's the irony it actually
it's within a couple of percentage
prices it actually has been a priority
and and jamie foxx who got an oscar for
for ray right uh
said uh
great movie oh i've seen that i've seen
that great movie i'm telling you i would
have
sent up letters upon letters i would
have burnt down the oscars if he did not
get something for that movie
i'm telling you that man
said okay ray i'm gonna take your soul
out of your body and i'm going to
encompass you he became ray charles and
there
i would put money there is nobody else
that could have done that no and can we
talk about blind men cheat now
you can't even see in the movie
it was all about the rest it was all if
it was super little chunky no ma'am
i need a slim rest wrist
i i saw it a long time ago so i i don't
remember it too well because i watched
it when i was a kid i haven't seen it in
a couple of years but i just remember
being a kid and being like he's blind
and he's still cheating
like how i me
i mean a great movie that's not that was
not the point of the movie i just needed
to put that in this reaction
i mean if it's you ain't got to be you
ain't got to see to know what to do so i
mean if it works